here are another 10 vu clips all dealing
with topics coming up in terms of
religion and questions or comments that
were put to me by users of the
now-defunct social network the UVU
allowed users to upload two-minute video
shorts as responses to questions or
comments by other users or by anonymous
people just sort of looking through the
things so I had quite a few questions
that didn't really fit into general
category other than somehow dealing with
religion ranging from you know francis
of assisi to biblical interpretation to
evolution to you know all sorts of other
related topics in any case here they are
perhaps you'll find them enjoyable or
interesting or who knows perhaps even
illuminating but I would like to stress
that I'm not you know trying to speak as
the theists or representative of
established religion or something like
that these are questions people are
putting to me I'm not particularly
interested in apologetics or that sort
of thing but here you go
do I really believe the Bible is the
Word of God the simple answer to that is
yes but like so many other simple
answers what that conceals the fact that
people believe a lot of different things
pertaining to that that expression the
Word of God as well as the Bible so I
have to clarify that first off let me
say that when people talk about the Word
of God
I think of Scripture but I also think
even more of the second person of the
Trinity which is the word of God Oh
logos and that is is is prior to
Scripture both temporally and in terms
of ontology in terms of being right you
have the word the Sun and then you have
the language the revelation the
communication about it but you know
before anybody start writing stuff down
about this guy this guy was here and he
was talking with people and he was
interacting with them my view on the
Bible is not that there is you know some
sort of divine command in all cases and
God said right right and I think that
actually did happen in some cases where
it actually said that that was the case
but I think in most cases God
collaborates with human beings through
you know traditions through schools
through the the situations that they
find themselves in so for example the
Book of Isaiah biblical scholars think
that there was actually a whole Isaiah
in school and that maybe there was a guy
as they at the start who starts writing
some of the stuff and then his some of
his people in his tradition are writing
later stuff I don't have any problem
with that and I don't have any problem
was seeing that as a collaborative work
between God and human beings other
people probably wouldn't like that idea
this is a really puzzling question in
parkas a lot of the stuff thrown in here
and it's like it's like a rollercoaster
ride right lurch large large large how
do I feel about all the rape sacrifice
murder sexism and homophobia let's say
we just stop you right there right
not for rape not for murder sacrifice it
really depends on what's being
sacrificed and you know we make
sacrifices every day sexism and
homophobia you know I'm not a radical
feminist that I'm not a gay rights
activist so I leave that sort of stuff
there's a kind of a division of labor I
don't feel myself under obligation to
condemn condemned condemned you know
when there's plenty of people out there
doing that already I'm not for it but
I'm not particularly worried about it so
we've got that and then how do you feel
about all this that God condemned in the
old testament well uh if it's bad things
that God is condemning then I think
that's good right do I just not count
that I have no idea what that means
because I don't even know the context of
the first question do I not count it Who
am I I'm not I'm not some major biblical
scholar voice you know forming the
conscience of a generation and I'm you
know like I've made clear and other
discussions about atheism and
Christianity I'm not somebody who
actually feels the need to defend
Christianity at great lengths against
those who are its cultured despisers
maybe this question has a different
context though maybe it's really about
continuity between the Old Testament or
that actually if you want to be specific
parts of the Old Testament with each
other and then to the New Testament and
if that's the question yeah I'm a big
believer in continuity I actually am
interested in the continuity between Old
Testament you know all the way leading
up to the New Testament and through the
patristic period in the medieval period
so if that's what you're talking about
made
that's yeah
okay so third time recording this since
I ran out of time both times I'm going
to try to be very very brief and this
could be something for me to address in
my doctor Sadler chalk and talk talks
which I actually started tonight and I'm
uploading to YouTube as we speak you
believe in evolution if so how are you
Catholic catholics haven't had a problem
with evolution for a long time I would
suggest reading some Catholic thinkers
particularly some contemporary ones and
seeing what they actually say most
Protestants also believe in evolution
Eastern Orthodox believe in evolution I
don't think you're going to find a lot
of Christians who actually reject the
notion of evolution as a way in which
species you know transform and develop
over time they're going to have they're
going to see more to the picture of
course but they're not they're not
against evolution the way that say a
hardcore fundamentalists are by the way
don't mix up fundamentals of
evangelicals either because that's
that's a really big mistake but a lot of
people make a lot of Evangelicals don't
have a problem with evolution how can
you favor a rational ideology to what we
know to be true I suspect that the way
that you're speaking for might be a bit
smaller than you you think that it is if
you think that Catholics are against
evolution irrational ideology is very
easy to to throw that term around but
you actually have to be able to
substantiate that and you have to
actually know you know who you're
referring to in that case if you're
talking about you know fundamentalist
supposed to - evolution okay I don't
have a problem calling that irrational
ideology if you're going to throw out
you know the entire history of Catholic
thinkers might want to read them all
first right or at least a good portion
of them first - what we all know to be
true as a matter of fact you know not
everybody who writes about evolution
agrees about precisely what evolution is
and they haven't over the course of the
past I would suggest read Jack barzoon
for us a good history of ideas on that
so all right
well I have to admit that on this you
have asked me about something that I had
to actually start going back to the
Catechism and early authors and some
papal encyclicals and take a look at
because this isn't something I've
actually thought much about Norway had
been particularly concerned about it so
what you're asking me Adam and Eve is a
wonderful story to illustrate God's
relationship with us but is not factual
according to the Catholic Church as far
as I can tell according to the Catholic
Church it is factual if by factually you
mean that the church does assert that
there were some primal parents created
by God and that humanity is sprung from
them I think what's important in
thinking about this is to ask yourself
what turns on it yeah it is in fact a
wonderful story to illustrate God's
relationship with with human beings you
know the the notion of us being created
out of out of the dust or the elements
and also the the spirit or the breath of
God that's that's wonderfully depictive
just reading gregory of nyssa
yesterday talking about that talking
about the material world in the
intelligible world and how they're
they're fused together you know on the
story of the fall the story that Eve is
created out of Adam's rib and one one
creation story and then the other
creation story also in Genesis that male
and female he created them both both in
the image of God these are all great
things I don't think that define that
sort of meaning in it you have to deny
the literality of it but again something
I haven't thought a lot about so maybe I
have to devote devote more thought to it
is that my
anonymous questioner asking about
catholics and evolution and all this
sort of stuff is actually after so they
asked catholics do believe the Advent
Eve story literally how can they agree
with evolution do you think that we did
we came from a demur apes it's both
they're not incompatible there's no
problem for Catholics in thinking that
evolution takes place there's a problem
in thinking and this is where the church
has been very clear there's a problem in
thinking that that therefore sort of
vacates got that God is not part of the
picture as a result and to think that if
evolution actually does take place or
even if they're you know a theory of
evolution is true that that somehow
negates God and God's agency that's the
result of a false dilemma and some
overly rigid thinking in terms of both
science and and theology so I don't have
any problem for example he has a
Catholic and again I'm not a theologian
we're getting way way out of my area I'm
a philosopher I'm not a theologian so my
job is not to interpret Scripture or
anything like that but I have no problem
thinking of God working behind the
scenes you know intervening here here
here here in very you know marginal
imperceptible ways to eventually through
the mechanics of evolution produce a
hominid pair capable of language
rationality all those things that you
know classical Christian theologians and
philosophers have seen as being part of
the image of God let's call that hominid
pair Adam and Eve see this doesn't seem
to be a problem for me I think it winds
up being a problem for for some
Christians and a lot of it turns on what
we mean by literally and what we mean by
by evolution but those are not terms
that we have you nib achill uses for
so where does Christ plank in your eyes
statement then that is the gospel verse
where he says before you start picking
out the splinter in your brother's eye
get the plank out of your own meaning
before you start trying to reprove
others and to guide them out of their
own more minor sins take care of your
own sins so if you have anger problems
you need to get your own anger problems
under wraps
and understood and controlled and you
know in some way that poisons run out
before you can start criticizing and
actually thereby helping others now a
lot of people take this verse as they do
some of the other verses as an excuse
not to make judgments not to confront
people when they're doing wrong doesn't
mean anything of the sort if you put it
in context with other verses what it
means is you don't place burdens upon
people that you yourself cannot handle
and you look to yourself every time that
you start you know being tempted to
reprove somebody else you have to ask
yourself is that do I have a problem
with this because it really is against
what is good for them against their
flourishing against what God wants for
them or is it I just have a problem with
it because I've got my own problems if
it's you if you've got your own problems
you have the plank Christ is not
asserting in this as a lot of people
think that well everybody's going to
plank in their eyes so therefore nobody
can say anything
and that's not how it's been interpreted
by by Christian thinkers down through
the ages it's interesting I came across
that discussion in my research on anger
John Cassian actually makes quite a bit
out of that
to that line so maybe that helps maybe
not I'm not a theologian
those are just my reflections
so really two issues here what should
you make of the plank in your eye gospel
verse does it mean that you should not
actually tell people that they're doing
wrong or confront them or take a stand
on things even if that stand happens to
be one that's that's grounded in
Scripture and Christian life I'm going
to talk about that one in the other one
and then st. Francis everybody likes to
quote that that one verse but they don't
actually do a lot of reading of the rest
of st. Francis alright so here's
something from the little flowers one
day at st. Francis was praying in the
shelter at Porton Alcala he saw through
divine revelation the shelter surrounded
and besieged by demons as numerous as a
great army but not one of them could
enter into the shelter for those friars
were such sanctity that the demons found
no place in which to enter but yet they
persevered and it came to pass that one
of those friars within was angry with
another and was thinking in his heart
how he could accuse him and avenge
himself while he was prey to this evil
thought a devil fighting an opening
entered into the shelter and a lighted
lighted on and clung to the neck of the
brother the pious and solicitous
Shepherd who always watched over his
sheep seeing that the wolf had entered -
devours lamb had that brother brought to
him he immediately ordered him to reveal
the poison of the hatred he had for his
neighbor which hatred had made him fall
into the enemy's hands the frightened
brother seeing that the Holy Father had
seen into him confessed his poison and
hatred acknowledged his fault and humbly
asked for merciful penance when he had
been absolved from the sin and received
from the received his penance the devil
left him the brother freed from that
cruel beast by the Good Shepherd gave
thanks to God he returned reproved and
perfected into the fold of the Holy
Shepherd and lived thereafter in great
sanctity and praise of Christ on men so
what is preached the gospel at all times
sometimes these words have to do with
the you know notion of not confronting
people because one is once off the
center absolutely nothing and if you
look through the rest of Saint Francis's
life
yeah thanks for actually putting this
because I think we have a lot in common
I was probably doing a lot of lot of
young young maybe then become
middle-aged men well I'm not going to
speak for how old you are
but I'm clearly middle-aged I'm 40 years
old a bit bitter cynical no Adele whom
asked fear that was me too longing for
the pods the pigs were eating woke me up
and that's kind of interesting because
there were there were a couple key
transitional moments for me and I know
that one of them for me had to do with
coming back to the church and that
didn't take place until I was in
graduate school and when I came back and
went to reconciliation and part of my
penance was to read Luke chapter 15
which of course contains three is
contained several parables and one is
the prodigal son and when I read that it
really struck a chord in me but by then
I was you know in my late 20s and I'd
really managed to screw up a lot myself
you know and it it hit home and I think
with some of these things you're not
ready for it to hit home your anger
hasn't really worked its way through and
become bitter enough for you to want to
be
released of that
until you reach a certain point we could
talk a lot about these these issues
having to do with anger and how it fits
into people's beliefs you know they
believe some things because they're
angry and they reject other beliefs
because they're angry and where does
this anger come from and all there's a
lot of questions that's part of why I
did research on anger I haven't gotten
rid of it entirely but but I've made
some progress thank God
so it's Sunday and all the Christians
are at church even though the Sabbath is
supposed to be Saturday breaking your
own God's rules so I'm guessing this is
sort of a continuation of the line of
questions that I had over the last I
guess what two weeks people you know
posing conundrums about Christianity or
religion or you know belief in God or
any of those sorts of things this
actually has to do with with some early
church history you're right the Jewish
Sabbath according to the old law and and
you know it's pretty clear you're
supposed to honor the Sabbath right
you're supposed to keep the Sabbath it's
very clear that you're supposed to
comply with that no wiggle room in the
old law that's on Saturday because you
know think of the Genesis account first
date is this second day third day
seventh day even God rests so human
beings are supposed to rest it's
interesting - it's not just a day
there's also supposed to be this whole
cyclical thing of allowing things to
rest and a lot of the rules are not just
about what you're supposed to do it's
about not imposing burdens on others on
the Sabbath in the early Christianity
there's a deliberate shift away from
Saturday to Sunday and why is that well
because it's to commemorate the
resurrection which is central to -
Christian doctrine and the Christian
experience so it's not as if they just
said ah screw the law you know or
something like that
they made you know the church leaders
and the laity they saw this is a
reasonable thing to do and it just kind
of stuck and that's what we have now
there are some Christians like for
instance seventh-day Adventist there are
some seventh day Baptist who worship and
hold their services on Saturday because
they think that that was a mistake some
of the adventist by the way since I'm
running out of time a little bit of
trivia one of the fastest-growing
denominations in the United States also
operate a lot of hospitals
okay so you're asking for my opinion on
this
not a canvassing of everybody's opinions
or anything like that in my opinion why
did you Judas Iscariot do what he did
what was he trying to accomplish was he
people I tend to go with the canonical
Gospels on this sort of thing I've you
know read the Gospel of Judas the non
canonical job Gospel that was discovered
a while back and it really does not
illuminate much and and there's no
reason to place a lot of credence in it
when you when you look at the the
narrative of where it fits in and all
that the canonical Gospels don't tell us
that much he seems to been motivated by
by greed because he took money for
betraying Christ although you know later
he throws the money back in the temple
and so it kind of sounds as if things
did not go entirely the way he had
intended them to go so you know there
are different theories out there the
ones that I find most interesting and
compelling are the ones that said that
Judas was probably a zealot who wanted
to see a more earthly Messiah who would
come and kick the Romans out and was
disappointed not to see that in Jesus
was very peaceable and you know
counseling things like love you know
love those who hate you and and all that
was he evil yeah actually I would say he
was evil
our acts are part of what make us what
we are and what did he choose he chose
to betray his friend and that's an evil
act and he chose to betray somebody who
was innocent and who had done nothing to
him except perhaps disappoint his hopes
and who had done so much good to other
people so yeah those are evil acts
um I think he was for that reason evil